[Música]
y
cómo
todo comenzó cuando yo era muy pequeño
cuando mis amigos salían a montar en
bicicleta yo me iba a casa de mi abuela
que tenía un perro un perro muy pequeño
que sea mayor o no yo llegan con mis
salchichas mis chuches me encantaba ir a
casa de mi abuela rápidamente me di
cuenta de que me iba a dedicar a
trabajar oa estar en contacto con el
perro durante el resto de mi vida
a los 18 años monté una escuela canina y
un hotel canino de lujo después me di
cuenta que lo que a mí me gustaba
realmente aparte de estar con los perros
era la seguridad y proteger con lo cual
monté una empresa de seguridad un tanto
atípica porque era una empresa de
seguridad exclusivamente dedicada a
trabajar con perros de seguridad y
vigilantes de seguridad hacíamos
binomios totalmente indivisibles
indestructibles
después en el año 2009 está denunciar
también internacional y haciendo una
pequeña exhibición con mis perros de
seguridad se me acercó una mujer y me
dijo mirándome los ojos
que necesitaba que le entrenarse el
perro para poder repeler las continuas
agresiones que estaba sufriendo por
parte de su expareja inmediatamente
empecé a darle vueltas empecé a ver que
el trabajo convencional del perro de
seguridad no era el trabajo que
deberíamos emprender con esta mujer ya
estábamos acostumbrados a trabajar en
circunstancias de alto riesgo con perros
de seguridad empezamos a indagar sobre
un instinto un instinto que está en la
naturaleza y que está poco
comprendido el instinto de protección y
el proyecto pepo se basó en ese instinto
de protección
en el primer momento pretendíamos que el
pp estuviese para cubrir ese espacio
tiempo crítico entre la víctima se
encuentra con su agresor y activa las
medidas telemáticas que le ofrece el
gobierno que son las pulseras el gps en
el mejor de los casos son cinco seis
siete ocho minutos en el que la víctima
de violencia de género se encuentra de
bruces y de cara con su agresor ahí
estaba el pp desde minuto cero empezamos
a ver que las virtudes que aportaba el
perro eran increíbles eran las virtudes
colaterales veíamos que ya estaba la
protección pero veíamos que el perro le
les apoyaba a libertad y les daba
libertad les daba ganas de salir a la
calle las empodera bah
bien un pp es un perro que reúne las
características especiales tienes un
perro social equilibrado gozar de una
impregnación exquisita cuando me refiero
impregnación es la fase que comprende
desde la tercera semana hasta
aproximadamente los 7-8 meses de vida
del perro todo lo que oiga vea sienta o
padezca lo va a relacionar con estímulos
que le suceden en un futuro y no va a
desarrollar ni taras ni fobias hacia
ellos son perros super sociales tienen
que tener un sentimiento de justicia y
tiene que tener un instinto de
protección nosotros a estos perros les
colocamos una dotación especial un arnés
que a partir de ahora va a ser el
catalizador de la protección el perro no
decide quién es el agresor y quién y
quién sí lo es la que lo decide es la
usuaria o la víctima de violencia de
género que apoyándose haciendo
movimiento mecánico que entrenamos en
este arnés el perro entra en modo
protección y no deja a nadie acercarse a
ella también llevan unos bozal es
especiales especialmente diseñados para
repeler agresiones sin causar heridas
graves empezamos a consensuar todos los
entrenamientos con psicólogos y con
psiquiatras
empezamos a hacer desarrollos tácticos
que son desarrollos tácticos situaciones
que simulan la realidad sin serlo y que
ayudan tanto a la mujer como al perro a
desenvolverse en situaciones reales
imaginaros una circunstancia
no quiero que vuelvas a bajar a la calle
con esos pantalones ajustados bien son
duras son palabras duras pero hay que
crearlas porque a través del
hipervínculo que creamos con el perro
aflora este instinto de protección hoy
en día tenemos 50 usuarias que ya
disfrutan de sus perros estamos formando
otras 10
la formación que reciben estas usuarias
es exquisita no os vais pensar que es
cuestión de y darles el perro no
ellas pasan por un curso de
aproximadamente 150 horas que las hace
adiestrador us es más muchas se dedican
ya el adiestramiento a trabajar se ganan
la vida adiestrando perros les damos
otro curso que son un curso de 20 horas
que es el que obliga a la ley a los
vigilantes de seguridad para poder
llevar perros de seguridad pues muchas
zonas son vigilantes de seguridad muchas
de las usuarias no estas ya son
vigilantes de seguridad luego les damos
otro curso este curso es de 20 horas y
es de perros de violencia de género y
ellas son partícipes en este curso hay
unas palabras que nos han hecho volar
una eminencia en psiquiatría de uno de
los mejores hospitales de españa dijo
conocedor del proyecto pp que ni en
siete años de terapia conseguía lo que
habíamos conseguido nosotros
en siete días
bien para mí
ver esa sonrisa que tienen cuando llega
su perro
es absolutamente increíble e
indescriptible lo que puedo sentir
cuando veo esa sonrisa después de estar
recuperadas os vamos a poner un vídeo
para que veáis un poco cómo funcionan
los pepos por esto yo no voy a poder
llegar a ti o qué
a
[Aplausos]
este es duque mi pp os voy a contar la
historia de cómo nos conocimos mi
historia es como la de cualquier mujer
que se enamora conoces a alguien que es
encantador maravilloso todo se le hace
poco para ti y nadie había tenido tantos
buenos detalles halagos piropos
piensas que pasarás el resto de tu vida
con esa persona tan maravillosa o al
menos es lo que la gente cree pero lo
que la gente no sabe es que cada mañana
te despiertas pensando
porque se enfadara hoy qué excusa tendrá
para insultarme para dejarme y anular me
y sabéis cuando deje de justificar todos
sus empujones y esos malos modales
cuando vi que también lo hacía con mis
hijos y dije basta
denuncié y empezaron los juicios las
órdenes de protección las visitas a los
niños y después de seis meses
se podía volver a acercar a mí no sé si
estáis al tanto de que esas órdenes de
protección caducan cuando mi protección
caducó él se acercó a mí e intentó
matarme pero afortunadamente no lo
consiguió y empezaron de nuevo los
juicios las órdenes de alejamiento la
escolta policial todos los medios que la
ley pone a disposición de las víctimas
de género
las medidas telemáticas esos grandes
medidas que lo que te crean esa ansiedad
angustia por todos los fallos técnicos y
de diseño que conllevan el aparato cada
vez que sonaba no sabía si era porque le
tenía al lado
o porque había partido de cobertura
suenan igual vives en el miedo constante
y os aseguro que es agotador pero
después de 8 años te acostumbras te
acostumbras a vivir con esa orden de
alejamiento y con ese miedo pero
entonces piensas y después de esa orden
después de que mi protección vuelva a
terminar que será de mí que será de mis
hijos volverá para terminar lo que un
día empezó
ahí conocí a el proyecto pp perros de
protección para víctimas de violencia de
género
me costó muchísimo el teléfono y
marcar
recuerdo que apenas me salía un hilo de
voz y al otro lado ángel
allí estaba para ayudarme no lo dudo
pase todas las entrevistas los filtros
todo todo lo necesario para entrar en el
proyecto y empezaron los cursos mi
primer curso rodeada de un montón de
hombres a los que ni siquiera podía
mirarle a la cara
me sentía pequeñita a su lado me
intimidaba muchísimo eran todos
vigilantes de seguridad pero ángel decía
que
que era una fase muy importante para mi
recuperación y ahí descubrí que había
seguía habiendo gente buena
pasé por mi primer seminario de
violencia de género y mujeres cuentan su
experiencia para ayudar a otras
lo pasé fatal tuve que salir de la sala
porque la angustia no me dejaba respirar
todos los recuerdos se agolpaban en la
mente
en ese momento ellas me enseñaron que
aunque lo veas muy negro
de ahí se sale
y ese mismo día tuve mi primer
entrenamiento pude comprobar lo que era
tener protección por parte de un perro
él es tango es un pastor alemán enorme
me arrodillé le abracé y ángel se acercó
hacia hacia mí increpándome diciendo
barbaridades tango empezó a gruñir sus
pechos se aceleraba cada vez más pero a
pesar de la situación no me puse
nerviosa
me sentí segura después de tantos años
había podido apartar el miedo por un
momento
al poco tiempo ángel me presento a mí
cachorreta de pep o el futuro gran pp
teníamos tiempo suficiente para poder
crecer juntos me quedaban dos años de
orden de protección
y cuando llego a casa fue todo un gran
cambio ya no me valía a decir que no
salía de casa tenía que salir sí o sí
a él había que sacarle si no quería
encontrar algún regalito por el suelo
entonces cuando cuando ya estaba en la
calle
ya no era yo la que miraba hacia atrás
él me avisaba de cualquier ruido y
cualquier presencia
giraba la oreja y me alertaba duque me
devolvió las ganas de hacer cosas nuevas
de el coche y salir de mi barrio
de conocer sitios que antes era
impensable ir sola mis hijos ya no
cerraban la puerta de casa con llave
el proyecto me cambió la vida pero
teníamos que comprobar si realmente
después de 16 meses de duro trabajo
había dado frutos si mi perro me
protegería y sabéis saludo y un momento
cuando vio que ángel me miró mal
y se acercó hacia mí amenazante
duke no dejo que se acercara
yo ya no estaba sola él estaba ahí para
evitar que me hicieran daño otra vez
él me quito todos los miedos el miedo a
salir a la calle el miedo a ir al parque
con mis hijos o el miedo an contable en
una conversación con extraños
me quito todos los miedos que te
susurran a la espalda y te recuerdan que
tu agresor sigue ahí y si él sigue ahí
pero yo ya no soy víctima ahora colaboró
soy parte del proyecto colabora ayudando
a otras mujeres que como yo llega en su
día totalmente hundidas con muchos
miedos y ninguna autoestima
ver como un perro te les devuelve las
ganas de vivir las ganas de salir las
ganas de ponerse guapas y conversa el
mundo
no hay palabras que describan ese
sentimiento
yo lo viví y ahora las ayudó a ellas a
que lo vivan también
el proyecto nos da seguridad protección
nos da confianza en nosotras mismas y
nos enseña que sigue habiendo gente que
merece la pena conocer
duke está siempre conmigo está en casa
en el trabajo
pero ahí
hay lagunas legales que estamos
intentando solventar puesto que si vamos
a algún centro comercial o algún cine o
algún sitio público no podemos pasar con
él en ocasiones no nos dejan por ejemplo
ayer nos impidieron pasar aquí pero
estamos luchando porque porque nos dejen
pasar porque nosotras no dejamos un
perro atado a la puerta lo que estamos
dejando es nuestra protección es nuestra
seguridad es nuestra vida y eso es algo
que tenemos muy claro queremos seguir
vivas y si él no pasa nosotros tampoco
y poco a poco vamos trabajando para que
más mujeres sigan vivas para poder
ayudarlas necesitamos financiación hasta
ahora todo todos los recursos han venido
por parte de ángel y su empresa
altruistamente no nos pide nada a cambio
ya vamos consiguiendo colaboradores
poquito a poco
pero somos muchas mujeres y muchas más
que empiezan a venir a pedir ayuda y no
sólo eso comisarías psicólogos
asistentes sociales e incluso el
instituto de la mujer no se llevan casos
y eso es porque el proyecto funciona
se ha corrido la voz
pero todos nosotros no podemos hacerlo
solos ya somos 50 mujeres en el proyecto
50 mujeres que pasamos de vivir en la
oscuridad para vivir en libertad otras
10 están en formación viviéndolo con su
pp con su cachorro de pepo y hoy todas
nosotras las 50 podemos decirlas a esas
que somos libros gracias a nuestro
compañero de vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]